hey everyone lucy here in this video i'm
going to be breaking down how i pass
through innovate certifications in three
months i'll be talking about the steps i
took
the resources i used and the mindset
that i adopted to keep pushing forward
so as a bit of an introduction i'm a
university student in sydney australia
and i currently intern at aws so the
reason i decided to make this video is
because i've been getting a lot of
questions from my friends
and students on linkedin who are
currently studying or thinking of
studying for certification exams
they've been asking me questions like
how did i prepare for these
certification exams
and what did i use to study for it as
well as questions like how did i find
time to dedicate to my cloud learning
journey
so hopefully in this video i'll be able
to address some of these questions
and let's get into it first it's about
getting into the right mindset and
knowing your why
why do you want to study for aws
certifications and what do you want to
get out of it
for some of you it might be your first
time learning about cloud computing
and you want to use certifications as a
way to not only follow a structured
learning pathway
but also validate your knowledge for
others these certifications might be
useful in your current or future role
so by studying for them you can build
your skills and apply it to your job
by knowing your why and setting an
achievable goal you'll find it much
easier to stay motivated during your
cloud learning journey
the next step is to study unfortunately
there's no shortcut or easy way around
this
and even people with many years of it
experience have to dedicate a few hours
to study for each certification exam
the good thing though is that there are
so many resources out there that can
help make your learning experience as
fun and engaging as possible
the way i approached this was to first
go through video courses and watch
theory lectures
once i understood the concepts at a high
level i followed along with lab
exercises that were offered by these
video courses
to gain hands-on experience so that i'm
not just forcing myself to memorize
stuff
but actually being able to apply it
after that i did practice questions and
for the ones that i got wrong
i'll read the written explanations and
go back to the video courses to revise
certain sections
so what i recommend doing is going
through a cycle of learning about
certain services and concepts
and then applying what you've learned by
playing around with the database
management console
and finally trying out practice exams to
see if you have any gaps in your
knowledge
so you might be wondering what resources
did i use to study for the aws
certification exams
and to be honest at the start it was a
bit of everything everyone had different
materials that they really recommended
and really vouched for
and i wanted to figure out which one was
the best for me and i recommend doing
the same
i've linked into the description below
the resources i found helpful
but i recommend getting free trials of
different courses and practice exams so
that you can decide for yourself
what resources to use personally i spent
most of my time going through video
lectures
taught by an instructor called stefan on
udemy and practice
questions from a website called
tutorials dojo
before i end this video i wanted to
leave you with some final tips to help
you pass your anabes exams
my first tip is to book your exams in
advance so that you can work backwards
from a specific
date and figure out how much time you
need to dedicate every week to studying
just remember that if you ever find
yourself needing more time reschedule
your exam at least 48 hours in advance
because you won't be able to change the
exam date and time for free after that
the next thing i wanted to emphasize is
that hands-on experience is a must
it's definitely possible to pass the
exam by doing tons of practice questions
without even touching the aws management
console but it's really easy for you to
forget everything you've learned right
after the exam if you don't bridge that
gap between theory and actual hands-on
work
my third and final piece of advice is to
block out some non-negotiable time each
week for your learning
to pass three aws certifications in
three months you don't have to study
every single day and sacrifice time with
family and friends
try to work around your schedule and
find free time slots where you can
really sit down and focus on the
material
thanks so much for watching please give
this video a like if you found it
helpful
and subscribe for more student and tech
related videos
if you have an aws exam coming up or
have any questions
please let me know in the comments below
bye for now